imagine two machines they both output
messages from an alphabet of a B C or D
machine one generates each symbol
randomly they all occur 25% of the time
while machine to generate symbols
according to the following probabilities
now which machine is producing more
information Claude Shannon cleverly
rephrase the question if you had to
predict the next symbol from each
machine what is the minimum number of
yes-or-no questions you would expect to
ask let's look at machine 1 the most
efficient way is to pose a question
which divides the possibilities in half
for example our first question we could
ask if it is any two symbols such as is
it a or B since there is a 50% chance of
a or B and a 50% chance of C or D after
getting the answer we can eliminate half
of the possibilities and we will be left
with two symbols both equally likely so
we simply pick one such as is it a and
after this second question we will have
correctly identified the symbol so we
can say the uncertainty of machine one
is two questions per symbol
now what about machine - as with machine
one we could ask two questions to
determine the next symbol however this
time the probability of each symbol is
different so we can ask our questions
differently here a has a 50% chance of
occurring and all other letters add to
50% so we could start by asking is it a
if it is a we are done only one question
in this case otherwise we are left with
two equal outcomes D or B and C so we
could ask is it D if yes we are done
with two questions otherwise we have to
ask a third question to identify which
of the last two symbols it is on average
how many questions do you expect to ask
to determine a symbol from machine two
and this can be explained nicely with an
analogy let's assume instead we want to
build machine one and machine two and we
can generate symbols by bouncing a disk
off a peg into one of two equally likely
directions based on which way it falls
we can generate a symbol so with machine
1 we need to add a second level or a
second down so that we have two bounces
which lead to four equally likely
outcomes and based on where the disk
lands we output a B C or D now machine
two in this case the first bounce leads
to either an A which occurs 50% of the
time or else we lead to a second bounce
which then can either output a D which
occurs 25% of the time or else it leads
to a third bounce which then leads to
either B or C 12.5% of the time
so now we just take a weighted average
as follows the expected number of
bounces is the probability of symbol a
times one bounce plus the probability of
B times three bounces plus the
probability of C times three bounces
plus the probability of D times two
bounces and this works out to 1.75
bounces now notice the connection
between yes or no questions and fair
bounces the expected number of questions
is equal to the expected number of
bounces so machine one requires two
bounces to generate a symbol while
guessing an unknown symbol requires two
questions machine two requires 1.75
bounces we need to ask 1.75 questions on
average meaning if we need to guess a
hundred symbols from both machines we
can expect to ask 200 questions for
machine 1 and 175 questions for machine
2 so this means that Machine 2 is
producing less information because there
is less uncertainty or surprise about
its output and that's it Claude Shannon
calls this measure of average
uncertainty entropy and he uses the
letter H to represent it and the unit of
entropy
Shannon chooses is based on the
uncertainty of a fair coin flip and he
calls this the bit which is equivalent
to a fair bounce and we can arrive at
the same result using our bounce analogy
entropy or H is the summation for each
symbol of the probability of that symbol
times the number of bounces now the
difference is how do we express number
of bounces in a more general way and as
we've seen number of bounces depends how
far down the tree we are and we can
simplify this by saying that the number
of bounces equals the logarithm base 2
of the number of outcomes at that level
and the number of outcomes at a level
is also based on the probability where
the number of outcomes at a level equals
one divided by the probability of that
outcome number of bounces actually
equals the logarithm base 2 of 1 over
the probability of that symbol which
gives us our final equation entropy RH
is the summation for each symbol of the
probability of that symbol times the
logarithm base 2 of 1 over the
probability of that symbol and Shannon
writes this slightly different which
just inverts the expression inside the
logarithm which causes us to add a
negative though both formulas give the
same result so let's summarize entropy
is maximum when all outcomes are equally
likely anytime you move away from
equally likely outcomes or introduce
predictability the entropy must go down
now the fundamental idea is that if the
entropy of an information source drops
that means we can ask fewer questions to
guess the outcome and thanks to Shannon
the bit which is the unit of entropy is
adopted as our quantitative measure of
information or measure of surprise